this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
subscription every October thousands of
dead strip malls blockbusters and radio
shacks crawl out of their graves and
spring to life with orange signs while
Halloween spending has steadily grown in
recent years the number of pop-up stores
has absolutely exploded
companies like Party City and Spirit
Halloween have no trouble finding empty
50 60 thousand square foot buildings in
the middle of town for that they have to
thank the so called retail apocalypse in
the last three years alone
Sears lost 142 of its stores Toys R Us
filed for bankruptcy JC Penney lost
about 200 Payless Shoe Source closed all
2000 and RadioShack about a thousand the
obvious question is why and the obvious
answer is Amazon but not exactly it's
not retail stores that are dying all
these brands have something in common
they suck usually because they failed to
adapt Sears trying to do everything and
ended up doing everything terribly JC
Penney forgot its customers and Toys R
Us thought the internet was a fad
millenials didn't kill your business
they stopped putting up with its
eighteenth-century practices other
companies are thriving like Ross lush
Aldi and Dollar General one specifically
Costco succeeds
against all odds not by copying Amazon
but doing almost the opposite while both
sell just about everything from food to
tires vacations and lawnmowers Costco
strategy could hardly be more different
and that's exactly why Amazon should be
paying attention
most grocery stores cheap Premium big
and small have the same basic strategy
they know everyone buys milk eggs bread
and bananas and almost everyone knows
what they cost so they lure customers in
with cheap prices for these staples even
at a loss and then profit from their
large volume repeat business Costco is
no different with its $5 rotisserie
chicken and bargain gas stations which
usually attract long lines but unlike
almost all of its competitors
Costco's deals aren't aimed at the
general public while the average grocery
store does anything to get you in the
door
Costco charges you you won't even be
allowed inside without a membership
which starts at $60 a year or 120 for
gold star executive this like Amazon
Prime triggers a sunk cost fallacy
once you've already paid the 60 or 120
dollars you feel invested why shop
around when you already have Prime by
not using it you think you're just
wasting money soon you stop comparing
prices and automatically go to Amazon
but what's really genius about Costco's
membership is that it's mandatory Amazon
users will sell sort each individually
calculating whether buying Prime will
save them enough money to be worth it
this does create loyalty but doesn't
fundamentally change the company's
business model Costco on the other hand
makes 75% of its money from membership
fees membership isn't its loyalty
program membership is its business model
in 2018 Costco had 94 million members a
little less than Prime's 100 million
despite having only 700 stores around
the world that's significantly more than
cheaper digital subscriptions like Apple
musics 60 million or who lose 25 and yet
90 percent renew each year why because
as prices are so ridiculously low not
because it's a charity or makes money
from more expensive items while you're
already there but because its incentives
are aligned with yours
its first priority is getting its
customers to renew their membership
which means impressing them time after
time with low prices and high quality
raise
prices would only generate a few cents
today and cost the company $60 next year
that's why it has a self-imposed rule no
item can be marked up more than 15
percent or 14 for branded items giving
it an overall average markup of 11
percent for lower than Walmart's 24
percent 30 across all supermarkets or
Home Depot's 35 almost everything about
its stores is designed to accomplish
this goal true to its name Costco stores
are in every sense of the word
warehouses there is no back room instead
forklifts move pallets of products
directly onto store shelves there are no
fancy decorations and aisles filled
deliberately crowded basically the
opposite of an Apple store but for as
big as its warehouses are their
selection is surprisingly sparse your
neighborhood supermarket will sell on
average about 30,000 unique items a
Walmart Supercenter 140,000 but Costco
only about 4,000 many of its stores have
a gas station pharmacy hearing aid
center optometrist photo processing
center tire garage liquor store and food
courts but for each kind of item there
will usually be only one or two choices
rather than paralyzing shoppers with an
endless row of similar brands Costco
offers large quantities of whatever it
considers highest quality not only does
this make shopping and stocking shelves
simpler but it gives Costco immense
buying power and by extension immense
negotiating leverage with its suppliers
companies want so badly to be the one or
two choices at Costco their lower prices
and work to adapt their product to its
needs at one point for example Costco
re-engineered a container of cashews so
it could fit more in the same space
ultimately saving 24,000 pallets a year
money it passed on to the customer if
Costco is unsatisfied with a product it
just creates its own its store brand
Kirkland Signature accounts for about
25% of its annual sales and has a
reputation for being high quality the
other major ingredient to Costco success
is the way it encourages heist
because getting around the store is so
confusing you have no choice but to
wander through most of the aisles the
large quantities attract business owners
who make up just over one-third of its
total members but account for two-thirds
of its sales the $60 upfront fee
meanwhile selects for an affluent
demographic with an average household
income of nearly $100,000 and that's the
genius of Costco it turns nearly every
seeming obstacle into a competitive
advantage its membership fee should make
acquiring new customers fatally
difficult instead it creates loyal
deep-pocketed patrons who praise the
company for its free samples generous
return policy and of course low prices
its cost-saving warehouse layout should
confuse and annoy shoppers instead it
makes them feel like deal hunters much
in the same way I Kia's do-it-yourself
model makes its customers proud of their
work it's a winning formula that's now
being exported to 13 countries including
as of this year China its grand opening
in Shanghai was so busy that it had to
temporarily close for safety ultimately
costco will never be as big or exciting
as amazon and that's largely why it's so
adored shareholders love it as a solid
low-risk predictable long-term
investments and its customers can feel
good about its low prices knowing that
they don't commit the expense of workers
while amazon ruthlessly sacrifices
everything for lower prices costco sees
its employees as a crucial ingredient to
its success the average wage of all two
hundred and forty five thousand workers
is twenty one dollars an hour double the
US retail average it also gives better
health insurance and retirement benefits
which costco is rewarded for with
employees three times more productive in
an era of overvalued start-ups reckless
desire for growth and questionable
business practices costco is something
else entirely refreshingly boring as
companies like Walmart and Costco rushed
to compete in e-commerce there's never
been a better time career-wise to learn
programming brilliant we'll take you
from the fundamentals all the way
through the most advanced concepts
machine learning quantum computing and
everything in between
brilliant helps you really understand
science math and computer science with
interactive problems and graphics which
make learning fun and engaging you can
use the link in the description to start
learning whatever interests you the most
for free and the first 200 people will
get 20% off the annual premium
subscription so you can view all the
daily challenges and unlock dozens of
problem-solving courses thanks to
brilliant and to you for watching this
video